the White House pushed back on news
reports Tuesday that just 1.7 miles of
wall along our southern border had been
built with one point six billion dollars
allocated by Congress but even the real
number reveals that barely any wall has
been built meanwhile in the UK the
failure of Prime Minister Theresa May to
secure her national borders has her
Premiership in freefall if the US
doesn't get immigration under control
is President Trump headed for the same
fate then Quentin Tarantino rejects
feminism at the Khan Film Festival love
it and finally the mailbag I'm Michael
Knowles and this is the Michael Knowles
show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
1.7 miles of wall with 1.6 billion
dollars that was the allegation the real
number is better than that but it's not
much better than that
Sarah Sanders will explain and we will
analyze what it means for 2020 there are
a lot of things in life that just aren't
right like spending that much money on
that little wall and a couple other
things that aren't right or carpet and
showers eating dip with your fingers
chunky style milk that doesn't make
sense you know what makes even less
sense paying too much for your phone
bill that is just not right and I was
doing it for a very long time and you
almost certainly are doing it too and
you shouldn't because thanks to Mint
mobile you don't have to overpay for
Wireless anymore with mint mobile you
can cut your wireless bill down to just
15 bucks a month and by the way if
you're like me I was probably paying
five between five and ten times that
before with big wireless well mint
mobile has reimagined Wireless making it
easy and online only
it means they pass along significant
savings directly to you you can save
thousands of dollars a year using mint
mobile without sacrificing quality
service mint mobile makes it easy to cut
your bill down to just 15 bucks a month
how do you do it you use your own phone
with any mint mobile plan you keep your
old number along with your existing
contacts so how does it get all those
savings because it allows you to choose
between 3 8 or 12 gigabytes of 4G LTE
data so you can stop paying for
unlimited data that you are never going
to use that is how big data and big
phone comes and takes all your money
from you every plan comes with unlimited
nationwide talk and text if you're not
100% satisfied then mobile has you
covered with their seven day money back
guarantee
ditch your old wireless bill start
saving with mentok mobile get your plan
for just fifteen bucks a month get the
plan shipped to your door for free
mint mobile.com slash Knowles canner
wles this is a game changer mint mobile
comm slash Knolls cut your wireless bill
down to fifteen bucks a month get free
shipping on your mint mobile plant mint
mobile comm slash Knolls
all right I wish our federal government
was that interested in cutting costs and
saving money and actually getting
something affected here there was a
report out on Tuesday that outlets
outlets were saying that the trumpet
raishin had built only 1.7 miles of
border wall in two and a half years in
office and they had used 1.5 seven
billion dollars from Congress to do that
now because I read that in the
mainstream media I knew it wasn't true
it just sort of assumed
however just looking around looking at
the pictures on the border I don't see a
whole lot of new border wall and if the
Trump administration had built a whole
lot of new border wall you know that we
would have heard about it he would have
been tweeting it all the time tweeting
pictures tweeting videos giving rallies
down there so what is the reality of
this Sarah Sanders went on Fox and
Friends to discuss
he or she is shooting down the reports
from the mainstream media just building
on the wall comment first story in The
Drudge today it looks like the wall we
only have two miles built to the wall
what's going on there and this is the
president still thinking get 400 miles
done of the wall by the end of the year
absolutely and that's that's an
incorrect figure there's far more than
two miles at a min bill we're still on
track to get close to 500 miles built by
the end of the year the Army Corps of
Engineers working with DHS and DOD are
putting a tremendous amount of effort
into not just building new wall taking
down some of the barriers that have
existed that are completely ineffective
and putting in the the very effective
border wall that they've been building
over the last couple of months that's
going to continue and we're making great
progress on that front okay so you'll
notice the language shift that Sarah
Sanders has they say look they've only
built 1.7 miles of new border wall and
she says listen there is plenty of
border wall that is going to be built
and so what's missing in that statement
is is it old border wall or is it new
border wall all right they're gonna
build 500 miles she says first of all
it's in the future tense so if she's not
saying we've built 500 miles you're
saying by the end of the year by the day
after tomorrow we're gonna build 500 but
then she's also saying we're gonna we're
just gonna build wall okay is it
replacing old broken-down wall or is it
actually new border wall we already have
wall along our southern border good
want to update that we want to build a
lot more though and so you've got to
look to Customs and Border Protection to
actually get the real numbers here so
CBP reports that thus far 6 point 1
billion dollars has been allocated to
building the wall or the slats or the
really strong fence or whatever you want
to call it it estimates that this will
result in a total of approximately 336
total miles of border wall over the next
couple years so the White House is
saying 500 miles by the end of this year
Customs and Border Patrol which is
actually going to be affecting a lot of
this is estimating about 336 miles over
the next couple of years okay how much
of that is new wall reports from Customs
and Border Patrol are saying our
customers of border protection rather
are saying 86 miles of new primary wall
so you got 86 of that 24 miles of new
levee wall 68 miles of updated primary
wall 144 miles have updated vehicle wall
14 miles of updated secondary wall so
you're going through all of these
numbers the primary the secondary the
new the updated what does that mean it
means that ultimately only 110 miles of
this 336 mile promise is going to be new
wall 226 of it is going to be updated
now when President Trump promised the
wall I think a lot of us had in our
minds that there would be 2000 miles of
wall built maybe you don't need 2000
miles of wall maybe you just need it at
the hot spots or where people are
actually crossing okay but that's a far
cry from a hundred ten miles of new wall
over the next couple years it gets even
worse than this so 20 miles of new
border wall has been constructed through
this traditional funding process during
the Trump administration and
additionally there are about 40 miles of
new wall in place of pedestrian fencing
that was funded by the fiscal year 2017
budget but the fiscal year 2017 budget
comes from 2016 before President Trump
was in office so now even that number of
a hundred and ten you get down to what
do we have now we have 16
miles total and about 40 of it was
funded under Barack Obama so then you
have to ask how much of it was built
under Barack Obama even let's say none
of it even if you're just looking at
funding the majority of the new wall
that we have was funded by Barack Obama
in the last few months of his
administration rather than in two and a
half years of the Trump administration
this is a major political loss for the
Trump administration this is really bad
Ann Coulter one of the earliest Trump
supporters has been complaining about
this for months now over a year now and
saying Trump's not really building the
wall trump's not really building the
wall Trump fires back and says yes I am
I'm totally doing it and you've had this
political fight and and she said no it's
really not happening
some of president Trump supporters have
started to believe her I didn't want to
believe her
so no I'm sure they've got this under
control 60 miles of border 40 of which
were funded under the Obama
administration that's a total failure on
the promise of building the wall there
have been so many other wonderful
aspects of the Trump administration it
has vastly exceeded my wildest dreams
for how great it would be when you just
compare conservative domestic
legislation he's done better than Reagan
but what about the central promise where
is the wall I'm not just asking because
I want the wall to be built I'm asking
because if that was a central promise in
2016 how is President Trump going to
face voters in 2020 and explain why the
wall hasn't been built this is not just
an American problem this is not the
demand for border protection is not just
an American phenomenon this is going
around all over the Western world in the
United Kingdom right now as we speak
the UK is voting in the European
elections so the UK has its own
government and then the European Union
has its government now you probably
remember three years ago the UK voted to
leave the European Union so why are they
still voting in the European elections
they're still voting because brexit
never happened it
we were we were promised brexit
initially the date that the United
Kingdom was supposed to leave the
European Union was March 29th of this
year yeah that's gone okay so then it
was pushed back to April 12th of this
year is that nope that's gone to now
we're being told that they'll leave on
October 31st and if you believe they're
actually gonna do it I've got a bridge
in Brooklyn to sell you a major issue
Theresa May is the Prime Minister of the
United Kingdom for now she very likely
won't be Prime Minister for long because
she has failed to affect the brexit vote
she has failed to secure her national
borders polling shows that support for
Theresa May and her leadership of the
Tories of the Conservative Party has
collapsed
what is surging in her wake Nigel Farage
the guy who used to be the head of the
UK Independence Party he was one of the
main forces behind brexit he has now
founded a brexit party and polling shows
they are surging in the EU elections and
Faraj said that he's got over a thousand
candidates thousands of candidates ready
to stand for the UK elections the next
time that those will be up in a few
years how did this happen
it happened because people want to
protect their borders
by the way you won't see a lot of
reporting on the status of Theresa May
today or on the EU elections and the
brexit party because in the United
Kingdom they have laws to prohibit
reporting on elections during election
day so if you're wondering why this
isn't trending globally on Twitter or
something it's because the British press
legally cannot report on these elections
until the elections are over but the
mainstream media are stunned by this the
mainstream media in the UK and in the
United States the New York Times wonders
they have they have their big
explanation how Faraj is brexit party is
crushing its opponents they completely
get it wrong but the mistake that the
New York Times makes the mistake that
the elites in Britain make could spell
serious political trouble for Donald
Trump if he doesn't fix it we'll get to
that in a second but speaking of safety
rings mission is to make neighborhoods
safer you might already know about their
smart video doorbells and cameras that
protect millions of the
everywhere you might know because I talk
about mine all the time and how it makes
me feel so safe security is a big issue
these days it's a geopolitical issue
it's a national issue and of course it
is a personal issue ring helps you stay
connected to your home anywhere in the
world if there's a package delivery or a
surprise visitor you will get an alert
and be able to see here and speak to
whoever is at your door all from your
phone that's thanks to the HD video and
two-way audio features on ring devices I
love mine I can be connected to ring to
whoever is coming to my home from
anywhere in the world whether I'm in my
bedroom whether I'm at the office
whether I'm on a beach in the Caribbean
our senior producer J hey the other
night he's lying in bed with his lovely
wife they're sleeping it's 3:00 in the
morning
two wacko drug addicts show up to his
door ring the bell
they were casing the joint they wanted
to see if anyone was home he starts
talking to them right away sees them he
says what do you want they say oh uh uh
homina homina nothing and they run away
because they know he could have done
that whether he was on vacation too it
just makes you safer as a listener you
have a special offer on a ring starter
kit available right now with a video
doorbell and motion-activated floodlight
camera the starter kit has everything
you need to start building a ring of
security around your home go to ring.com
slash knowles kayano wles ring.com slash
knowles really makes you feel much safer
The New York Times the mainstream media
still somehow years later don't
understand this issue of border security
and this issue of immigration this is
what they wrote how Faraj is brexit
parties crushing its opponents they're
describing the brexit rally seen the
candidates walk down the ballroom aisle
to loud ovations and corporate rock
taking turns at the lectern delivering
pitches for the brexit party a deep
pocketed tory known for churning through
managers at his soccer club annex labor
voter and son of a coal miner whose
hometown despised Margaret Thatcher a
dental surgeon who said in an interview
that she believed the European Union was
indoctrinating children like Stalin's
kids and comas Amal and Hitler Youth one
by one they let loose for the bare-bones
populace and largely bereft of
any demonstrable political ideology or
for that matter any detectable policies
save one taking Britain out of the
European Union promptly and if necessary
with no deal no issues you see the New
York Times they just they can't
understand why is the brexit party
surging in the polls they have
absolutely no issues whatsoever
oh yeah well except for pulling Britain
out of the European Union but they have
no real issues you see according to the
New York Times national security
immigration that's not a real issue a
real issue would be something like
raising taxes or lowering taxes a real
issue would be changing some aspect of
the health care system a real issue
would be the green new deal because the
Sun Monster is going to destroy the
world in 12 years and so we need to
outlaw planes trains and automobiles and
knock down every building in the country
that would be a real issue according to
the New York Times but securing national
borders protecting national sovereignty
protecting self-government immigration
legal and illegal those are not real
issues this is the mistake they make
this is the mistake Democrats and
Republicans have made in the country and
frankly if the Trump administration
cannot build more wall it's a mistake
that the president is going to be making
as well this is a big issue this is not
just a big issue this is the big issue
because it touches on so many aspects of
politics one security really matters if
people don't feel secure they don't care
about anything else in politics so it
touches on a question of personal
security it touches on questions of
culture you've got people coming in and
out of countries in the United Kingdom
in Europe in the United States who
aren't speaking the languages who are
not engaging in the political customs of
those regions who are not respecting
local laws I mean they're literally not
respecting laws when they come into the
country illegally and then at a really
basic bedrock level the question of
immigration illegal and illegal gets to
the question of self-government all of
our Western come
raise all of these developed countries
have a political tradition of
self-government so that people get to
decide who governs them what their laws
are how they're going to live what rules
they're going to follow when a small
cabal of elites decides to flood the
country either legally or illegally with
immigrants who will then eventually they
or their or their children will have the
right to vote in shape that government
you were getting into the question of
sovereignty who gets to rule who gets to
decide on this brexit question who gets
to rule and who gets to decide some
elites in Brussels or the British people
who gets to decide who goes in and out
of the United Kingdom some elites in
Brussels or the British people the
mainstream media want to convince you
that somehow it is wrong or immoral to
care about immigration
you see it's okay to care about health
care it's okay to care about any other
political issue but for some reason
caring about immigration policy is wrong
you know in the United States and in
various parts of Europe there were very
strict immigration policies in place and
at different times until very recently
in the United States until 1965 until
Ted Kennedy's immigration law we really
controlled our immigration system pretty
well since then our immigrant population
as a share of the total u.s. population
has tripled or quadrupled we have the
highest foreign-born percentage of the
population in the United States right
now that we have had since the 1890s it
is perfectly reasonable for people to be
concerned about that it's this isn't
just some bigoted reaction to to an
trivial issue this is a major change in
national policy it poses serious
problems for the culture and for
politics and so it's perfectly natural
for people to respond you know in the
United States we're talking about
low-skilled illegal immigration from
Central and South America in the
European continent we're talking about
whole masses of Muslim immigrants coming
over who were hostile to the culture who
don't speak the language who don't
follow the faith that crafted Europe who
are hostile to many laws and
and what we are told not just by the
elites not just by the mainstream media
but even by our own religious
institutions we are told you have to let
them in you can't do anything you can't
oppose it this is true in the faith that
crafted Europe in Christianity this is
true of virtually every Christian
denomination this is true perhaps
especially of the Catholic Church there
is one guy as far as I can tell there is
one major figure in international
Christendom he's a Catholic Cardinal
named Raymond Burke who is a very
conservative Cardinal very sharp guy
really has a great deal of moral clarity
on these questions he came out and he
said listen folks you don't have to
support open borders to be a good
Christian here he is here is someone who
resists large-scale Muslim integrate
immigration committing an immoral act
and therefore should be lets say denied
Holy Communion or or in some way
recognized as a public sinner to resist
large-scale Muslim immigration in my
judgment is to be responsible in the
sense of making sure that those who are
immigrating to the country remember that
the definition of the Church's teaching
is that the individuals are not able to
find a way of living in their own
country and this is not true of
immigrants who come who are opportunists
and in particular in the case of of
Islam which by its definition is
believes itself to be destined to rule
the world
coming in large numbers to countries you
don't have to be a rocket scientist to
see what's happened for instance in
Europe in countries like France and
Germany and also here in Italy and it's
also happening in the United States it
is happening in the United States
Cardinal Burke would know that because
he's an American he goes on to say that
it is not not
not immoral to oppose unfettered
immigration but actually it's
responsible it's a responsible act of
patriotism
it's a responsible act of prudence you
know charity is a virtue it's wonderful
to have charity prudence is also a
virtue and not letting huge limitless
numbers of people who are hostile to you
your culture and your system of
government to flood into your country
especially countries that have a system
of self-government
so eventually they'll be able to change
the government over time that's that's
perfectly prudent to oppose that it's
unfortunately the Catholic Church is
probably never going to make Cardinal
Burke Pope I don't think that's gonna
happen but if he keeps talking like this
he could probably run for president in
the United States in 2024 he could
probably run for the Prime Minister of
the United Kingdom because even if the
elites don't don't understand what he's
saying the people in both of those
places do this is a major issue poll
after poll shows this the majority of
Americans according to in ABC Washington
Post poll feel that too little is being
done to prevent illegal immigration
that's not the majority of Republicans
not the majority of conservatives the
majority of all Americans only one-third
of Americans believe our border is
secure enough Gallup polling shows that
77 percent more than three-quarters of
Americans want to stop the flow of
illegals totally a Harvard Harris poll
last year showed it's not just that
people want to radically reduce illegal
immigration they want to radically
reduce in the United States legal
immigration as well the majority want to
reduce legal immigration by upwards of
60% why because of the very real fear
that immigrants pose a threat to our
cultural traditions and system of
government if they do not assimilate and
if they come in in huge numbers and are
not made to assimilate this is not just
about speaking English rather than
Spanish this is not just about watching
baseball rather than soccer this is
about self-government and there's such
an irony today when you look at a
prominent immigrants in the United
States
Ilhan Omar democratic congresswoman
freshman in Congress she is an immigrant
herself she
fled a horrible country a country that
was wrecked by a socialist dictatorship
she fled Somalia she was finally able to
come with her family in 1992 to the
United States and what is she doing now
she is advocating the same policies that
helped to ruin the country that she fled
from if she wanted to continue to live
under those policies why didn't her
families stay in Somalia why did they
escape to something better only to turn
that better place into the same rotten
political culture that she fled you see
this a lot with the the question of
illegal immigration on our southern
border there's an organization they've
since changed their name because they
were getting bad PR called la raza means
the race this was on virtually every
college campus in the country started
here in Southern California and it's a
Hispanic supremacist group I don't know
how else to say it
now they've restyled it Unidos because
it's very difficult to say you oppose
racism when your your group is it called
the race at a lot of La Raza marches and
protests and a lot of immigration
protests and a lot of illegal
immigration protests that I have
personally witnessed from sea to shining
sea from Washington DC to Southern
California you will see people waving
the Mexican flag you will see illegal
aliens waving the Mexican flag if you
want to live under the Mexican flag go
back to Mexico
problem solved good we agree people who
oppose illegal immigration want you to
go back to Mexico you yourself just say
you want to go back to Mexico go back to
Mexico why are you here now they don't
really mean it no they don't want to go
live in Mexico they fled these places
they don't want to live in Somalia they
fled those places they want to come to
the United States because it's much much
nicer to live in the United States and B
yet when they're here and it's not just
their fault by the way this is being
encouraged by the popular culture it is
being encouraged by the left not to
assimilate it's being encouraged by a
leftist culture in America that hates
itself that hates the West that hates
our traditions that hates our
system of self-government that rewrites
and lies about our history that says we
are the worst place on earth and
everyone should we shouldn't support
immigration to be nice to the people
living in squalor and living under
threat of death
we shouldn't support immigration to give
them a better life we should support
immigration so that they can come here
and erase our own culture and bring over
their obviously superior culture from
Honduras and El Salvador and Somalia
that's that's the argument when you boil
it down that they are making
obviously it's ridiculous it's exactly
the opposite of reality but you're
seeing that play out and it is it is
really driving people from the u.s. to
the UK to Europe up a wall this issue
caused Teresa may to have the worst
Premiership ever it got her thrown out
early very likely will get her thrown
out of office will the failure to build
the wall get president Trump thrown out
of office hard to say he has some
advantages over me may was only in there
to affect brexit that was her that was
her whole job president Trump was not
just elected to build the wall he was
elected to fix the economy to create a
lot of jobs to bring some manufacturing
back he was to give us good conservative
judges originalist judges he has done
all that he succeeded very well in that
so he does have an advantage still a
major pillar of that campaign was
securing the southern border and that
has not happened we have 3,000 illegal
aliens per day pouring across a totally
porous border I get that it's hard being
president is hard and the American
people are not going to reward you for
trying they're not going to if this
remains a top issue or the top issue it
doesn't matter how hard you tried I get
it that the Democrats and the
bureaucracy are shutting this down at
every turn doesn't matter the buck stops
with the president we have a lot more to
get to we will get to Quentin Tarantino
shutting down feminism at Khan and we
will get to what that says about the
left and the right we will get to what
that means for the emotional Appeals
that the left and the right half because
they each have a special tool in their
toolbox and we're
have to make sure that we use the one
that we have if we want a chance in 2020
plus we got the mailbag but first go to
daily wire.com
ten bucks a month hundred dollars for
annual membership you get me at the end
or Clavin show you got the Ben Shapiro
show you get the amount wall show you
get to ask questions in the mailbag
coming up you get to ask questions
backstage you get another Kingdom I
could be here all day telling you what
you get but what you get most
importantly is the leftist tears tumblr
get it this is this is as important as
anything as we head into 2020 as the
2020 EMA crime area heats up you're
going to need it or you're gonna drown
go to Daley wire.com we'll be right back
shifting gears just slightly we go to
the European continent we go to the Khan
Film Festival Quentin Tarantino was
there he was asked a question about his
new movie Once Upon a Time in Hollywood
and but it wasn't asked a question
really about the movie or about the
story or about his legendary career in
film he was asked a question about why
he isn't feminist enough and he handles
it beautifully
Quentin you have put Margot Robbie a
very talented actress actor in your film
she was in the Leonardo with Leonardo in
wolf of wallstreet i Tania this is a you
know person with a great deal of acting
talent and yet you haven't really given
her many lines in the movie and I
wondered I guess that was a deliberate
choice on your part and I just wanted to
know why that was that we don't hear her
actually speaking very much and Margaux
I wanted you to also comment about being
in the film in this part well I just
reject your hypothesis I like I said
like I said earlier I I I always look it
to the character and what the character
is supposed to serve to the story I
think the moments that I got on-screen
gave an opportunity to honor Sharon and
the lightness I don't think it was
intended to delve deeper than like Brad
also mentioned I think the tragedy
ultimately was the loss of innocence and
to really show those wonderful sides of
her I think could be adequately done
without speaking first of all what a
stupid question from this Minh deled
this wonderfully this answer but what a
stupid question from that reporter I
mean obviously she doesn't know anything
about film so hey filmmaker how come you
didn't write the movie that I wanted you
to write how come you wrote the movie
that you wanted to write hey hey hey
Star Wars I thought that Boba Fett
should have been the star of the movie
instead of Luke Skywalker why didn't you
do that oh because I made my movie and
not your movie and if you want to make a
movie
can make your own movie the premise
though is even more ridiculous than that
because Quentin Tarantino has created
probably the strongest female characters
in the history of cinema just a quick
look down his history
you've got broom-hilda in Django
Unchained you've got Arlene in death
Proof you've got Jungle Julia in death
Proof you've got Abernathy in death
Proof you've got Kim Mathis in death
Proof death Proof literally ends spoiler
alert
with a group of women punching a man to
death you've got Alabama Whitman in
through romance you got Mia Wallace in
Pulp Fiction you obviously have the
bride in Kill Bill the entire Kill Bill
franchise is about a woman killing a man
named Bill also spoiler alert I guess it
was in the title Quentin Tarantino has
stronger female roles than any other
filmmaker but it's not enough for the
left is it that's the take away this is
actually how this ties in to our story
on open borders illegal immigration and
ultimately the elections that are coming
up it's never enough for the left you
can't you can't give them enough
appeasing the left is like appeasing a
militaristic dictator things might go
fine for a little while eventually he's
going to turn on you
eventually the left is going to turn on
you and why because beyond the arguments
of the left doesn't really have any
arguments left but beyond the arguments
the left and the right both have tools
at their disposal and the tool at the
left disposal it only has one its
resentment resentment for countrymen
resentment between races resentment
between sexes resentment for your
history resentment for your institutions
that is what the Left uses resentment
and so here to effect her left leftist
agenda this journalist if you can call
her that tries to gin up resentment
where it obviously doesn't exist to try
to portray Quentin Tarantino as some
anti-woman filmmaker all of his films
star women in really strong roles but
that's the way they do it the main
emotional tool of the right we make a
lot of arguments but the main emotional
tool that we have is actually the
opposite of the left stool
our main emotional tool is affection so
the left has resentment division
resentment between every class of people
every group of people every sexual
preference of people every country every
state every community what the right has
is affection affection for your
neighbors affection for your
institutions affection for your
traditions affection for the rituals
that you do affection for your country
this is why when you go to a right-wing
political rally it's like the 4th of
July it's what they talk about
patriotism they talk about love of
country they talk about love of family
they talk about love of God love of our
political traditions love of freedom and
when you go to a left-wing political
rally its screeching and whining and
complaining and vilifying and saying
this person is bad and this person is
the cause of all of our problems
this person is an oppressor America is a
horrible place we should ruin our past
we should forget our past we should pull
down monuments we should erase our
history we should bring in everybody
else from everywhere in the world and we
should take on their culture because our
culture is so awful and I hate
everything that's what the left says
what we have is affection and affection
is really strong affection is what gave
us the brexit vote affection is what
gave us the Trump 2016 election
affection is what can propel the right
to what I think is is a a quiet
conservative movement sweeping
throughout the Western world that's what
we've got to focus on and we don't have
time to check in on the 2020 race but if
you just take a look around those
candidates you'll see obviously they
can't they can't pull that tool out of
their belt they can't talk about
affection they just have to talk about
resentment people are sick of that
people don't like it make that
difference stark make that difference
clear and I think we'll have a fighting
chance let's get to the mailbag late as
we always are from mark Michael as a
member of the youngest part of the
Millennial Generation and or the oldest
part of Generation Z I'm 21 how do you
recommend I start going about finding a
suitable girlfriend who shares my views
specifically starting a family working
hard to provide them raising them in the
faith
etc Thanks first thing you got to do I
give this advice to people who write in
about love questions all the time you
got to change your language how to find
a suitable girlfriend so clinical
it's so sterile that doesn't sound sexy
at all that doesn't sound fun
I wouldn't want to do that don't don't
be so intellectual about it don't be so
clinical about it go out and find a girl
fall in love have a good time want to be
with them want to go find them chase
them get them that's what you want to do
the joke is colporteur never saying
let's do it let's be in a relationship
with a girl who shares some of my views
and aspirations it's let's do it let's
fall in love that's what it is go fall
in love that's the first thing now
you're saying when I put myself out
there to fall in love where am I going
to be able to do it with someone that
isn't gonna be some purple haired wacko
that I don't want to spend my life with
well you say you want her to share your
views on faith
maybe you meet her around Church circles
I'm not saying you know during the Holy
Communion you've got to start some
pickup lines with the girl next to you
in the pew but a lot of times after
church the churches that I attend
they'll have a little coffee or
doughnuts or something afterward maybe
hang around there maybe see how that
works
maybe get involved in some groups at
your church if you want to meet a girl
that you agree with politically go to
some events that are a little more
politically minded I'm a member of
probably a dozen political organizations
and you're not always there just
debating tax policy usually what you're
doing is having drinks and talking about
things that matter and having a good
time that's a good place to meet people
as well obviously the dating apps do
exist
I've been to multiple weddings of people
who met on those apps I think they can
be used for ill and they can be used for
very good just just as freedom can
always be used for ill or can be used
for good so maybe if you want to meet a
girl who's Christian you go on Christian
mingle if you want to meet a girl is
Jewish you go on JDate thats the one
right JDate if you want to meet a girl
that's Republican go on
Trump mingled calm I don't know if that
exists but if it doesn't it should there
are ways to put yourself in a situation
where you will be around like-minded
people probably you just do that
naturally we want to be around people
that we enjoy and that enjoy us but when
you're there don't don't be planning too
far ahead that it's it's the only way
that you can make love and sex boring
and don't do that because you know at
that point what's the point from Tommy
dear Michael what is your argument for
Christians to be pro-life I've run into
a lot of professing believers who
support abortion strongly thanks for all
your historical insights and your hard
work yeah I've noticed this to people
who say that their Christian and then
say that they support abortion there is
simply no way to be Christian and
support abortion I can't speak to the
other religions because I don't practice
them and I don't know a tremendous
amount about them but certainly in
Christianity there is no way to be
Christian and to support abortion it is
not possible what are some scriptural
arguments well the phrase conceived and
bore appears repeatedly in the book of
Genesis the first book of the Bible in
Psalms the psalmist says he was knit in
his mother's womb and he traces his
identity back to his moment of
conception in Psalm 51 verse 7 Luke in
the Gospel of Luke uses the same word in
Greek to describe children before and
after they are born obviously we're
talking about the same people and the
Apostle Paul writes quote God from my
mother's womb had set me apart and
called me through His grace from my
mother's womb God knew us before we were
born as we were formed in the womb hairs
on our head right this is throughout the
Old Testament and the New Testament
father Frank Pavone I think it is who is
the national director of priests for
life he has a great article on the
internet outlining some of the religious
arguments against abortion there's no
religious argument for abortion the
closest that anyone I've ever seen come
up with is a mistranslation of one verse
in the Book of Numbers which suggests
in in one bad translation in the NIV it
suggests that a a command from God could
lead in certain circumstances for an
abortion to be committed but no other
major translation renders it that way
and no other major translation suggests
that miscarriage or abortion or implied
at all in the text so there's just none
it's just a totally bankrupt argument
for people who are following the Church
of themselves you know this happens a
lot when people are say reading the
Bible without any interpretive scheme
without any context historical or
exegetical or from tradition or the
Church Fathers which is what it's like
is staring down a deep deep dark well
and when you look down into that well
all you see is yourself
on the surface you're just seeing your
own reflection you're reading into the
scripture whatever you wanted to say
you're following cafeteria Christianity
taking a little bit here a little bit
there and ignoring all of the rest you
say well it's so clear from this one
verse that I'm choosing to interpret how
I want to don't forget as dr. Johnson
famously said centuries ago all shallows
are clear shallow thinking is clear
shallow interpretation is clear and
profound things are a little more
complicated than that they have a little
more context than that obviously this is
true in divine revelation from Jack hi
Michael
you recently talked about jay inslee
governor of Washington and presidential
candidate and his composting program
composting dead bodies people who aren't
religious might not care about that form
of respecting the dead I think that
there's some sort of beauty in using a
dead person to give life to something
else it's certainly not worse than
burning them and keeping their ashes in
a jar my question is why is this bad
exactly from a non religious standpoint
well the composting our dead idea is bad
from a public health standpoint in so
much as this is going to lead to bubonic
plague
this very likely could lead to awful
public health outbreaks if you compost a
dead body a rotting body and then you
use that compost to grow other crops
you're really threatening
public health it is this is not terribly
sanitary that's just one reason the
reason that it is offensive though just
from a sort of ethical or philosophical
standpoint is that we Revere the debt
and we revere human beings we have
reverence for human beings they don't
lose that the minute that they die
because humans are not just their minds
or their spirits we are our bodies as
well we're a we're a unit where there is
a unity between our bodies and our souls
and so it is offensive to humanity per
se to desecrate a body I mean just think
about this very practically let's say a
very close family member of yours died
and then you said okay I know I'm gonna
dispose of the body and someone came in
and took the body and started throwing
it up in the air and juggling it and
stabbing it and urinating on it and
graffitiing it and doing all manner of
horrific things would you just say well
it's just a dead body it's nothing no
big deal
no you kill the guy you'd be so angry
because it is disrespectful to the
person who has died nevertheless it is
disrespectful to the person and so in
the same way letting dog because there
were bugs or something eat the dead is
also disrespectful it says that human
beings are no different than any other
animal just to be thrown out and
discarded but we're not we have dignity
we have an inherent dignity as by virtue
of the fact that we are humans and
therefore we should treat each other
with dignity while we are alive while we
are dead before we are born on the whole
spectrum of human life from Regan great
name excellent Michael Knowles thank you
for getting that right some people think
that people are referring to me around
here as execrable Michael Knowles but
I'm pretty certain it's excellent
Michael Knowles so thanks for getting
that right excellent Michael Knowles in
an interview his in an American history
class I am to give a presentation on
either the most effective or the least
effective political advertisement in
American history any thoughts Thanks yes
I'll give you just there are so many
great examples the Daisy ad that LBJ
used against Barry Goldwater was pretty
effective he used this in the 1960s and
it implied that barry goldwater was
going to blow up the whole world he was
a radical and yet his finger on the
nukes and this was at the height of the
Cold War and by all measures it was very
effective many other the Willie Horton
ad was very effective Ronald Reagan's
morning in America ad was very effective
there are so many good ones that we can
think of and I can think of some pretty
awful ads there was one from a candidate
christine o'donnell running for senate
in delaware who said as the thesis of
the ad i am not a witch
i because there was some accusation that
she had practiced Wicca or witchcraft in
her past and rather than just ignore
this or laugh about it she made a whole
video where she said I am NOT a witch I
am you I'm nothing you've heard I'm not
a witch and all people heard is oh my
god was this woman a witch oh dude I
didn't even know that someone suggested
she was a witch that was pretty bad that
was that was a pretty bad political ad
as well a few examples for you and there
are certain things that stand out I mean
negative ads do work when you attack
your opponents they do work ads where
you are defending ads where you are
explaining tend not to work because as
Ronald Reagan said when you're
explaining you're losing so you've got a
push hard boast on your successes ride
that success give people something to
aspire to but when you defend yourself
that's probably not going to work very
well we've got a whole lot more to get
to but we're out of time this is what
happens we just get too excited that's
our show have a good weekend tune in on
Monday I want to just quickly say our
thoughts and prayers are with the people
in Missouri and especially in Jefferson
City I was just out there a little while
ago in a major tornado has blown through
there so we're thinking of you and
praying for you hoping everything turns
out all right there and then I'll see
you on Monday come back here I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Nolt show
I'll see you then
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stevens edited by Dani D'Amico Audio is
mixed by Dylan case hair and makeup is
by Joshua alvera and our production
assistant is Nick Sheehan the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19
hey guys over on the Matt Walsh show
today NPR has issued an Orwellian
language guide for discussing abortion
telling us all the words and phrases we
should avoid or use when discussing well
I've got my own language guide that I'd
like to offer up for as a suggestion
also Quentin Tarantino has been accused
of sexism because the women and his in
his latest film don't spend enough time
talking apparently Jeff Daniels says
that democracy is coming to an end our
democracy is coming to an end if Trump
is re-elected and finally Michael
avenatti has been charged with fraud
we'll take a trip down memory lane and
remember all of the the time that the
media spent hyping this guy up hyping
him up as the savior of the republic
literally we'll do all that today over
on the Matt wall show